se nos pide graficar la función y es
igual a menos 2.5 coseno de un tercio de
x en el intervalo de 0 a 6 incluyendo
los extremos haré el mejor intento para
graficar esto así que para iniciar voy a
dibujar la función más sencilla o la
versión más fácil de esto entonces es
decir coseno de x así que lo graficó
eventualmente bueno voy aquí a dibujar
los ejes am este es el eje de las íes
ahí está el eje de la sien y quiero
tener algo de espacio para poder
eventualmente graficar todo esto digamos
que aquí están aquí está menos 1 aja
menos dos uno positivo y dos positivos
digamos que que esto de aquí es dos pi
entonces estos dos pin así que éste
puede ser
y ahora bueno voy a copiar esto porque
lo puedo usar después entonces voy a voy
a copiar esta gráfica o en los ejes para
graficar después todo entonces lo que
iniciamos con ye igual a coseno de x
cuando x y xi igual a 0 sólo lo haré en
el intervalo de 0 a 2 espn es una
función periódica así que seguirá en
ambas direcciones en la dirección
positiva y negativa porque es periódica
entonces qué sucede cuando existe igual
a cero tenemos uno ajá y qué tal cuando
existió a lápiz qué pasa cuando tenemos
con seno de pi cuando tenemos cocinó de
pi tenemos entonces esto es igual a
menos uno ajá
ahora con el coste no de 2 pib
nuevamente tenemos 1 y listo hemos
terminado un ciclo completamos un ciclo
y dos pies el periodo de la función
coseno de x así que la gráfica para
coseno de x se mira así y es periódica
así que bueno va a seguir
indefinidamente en ambas direcciones
entonces bueno yo aquí solamente dibuje
el ciclo entre 0 y 2 pi ahora pensemos
en qué pasa qué pasa cuando gráfica mos
en lugar de graficar ya igual a coseno
de x voy a poner aquí la gráfica que
copié en lugar de poner de dibujar igual
a coseno de x voy a dibujar ye igual a
coseno de un tercio de x la única
diferencia es que ahora estoy
multiplicando la x por este un tercio
qué va a pasar aunque pasara con la
gráfica como cambiará como como se va a
ver esto porque ya no va a ser x será un
tercio de x entonces lo haré en todo el
intervalo esta vez de 0 a 6 pi aquí
tenemos
34 p
y 56 para que pasara con esta gráfica
vamos a hombre
podemos pensar en esto como como para
completar todo el ciclo iremos un tercio
más rápido entonces entre un tercio más
rápido tres veces más lento a ver cuál
es el periodo de coste no de un tercio
de x el periodo es 2p dividido entre el
valor absoluto de este coeficiente
entonces tenemos que el período es 2
peas sobre el valor absoluto de un
tercio baja lo cual es simplemente esto
es igual a 2 y sobre un tercio es lo
mismo que dos por 3 entonces es igual a
6 pi y vamos bien hasta aquí y le tomará
tres veces más de tiempo estamos tomando
un tercio de x entonces x ahora debe
valer 6 pi para llegar a 2 pi como antes
normalmente lo hacía entonces el periodo
es ahora seis pi
así que cuando existe igual a cero un
tercio por cero es igual a cero coseno
de cero cuánto es eso
de cero es 1 entonces coseno de 0 aquí
aquí tenemos el valor 1 cuando x es
igual a 6 p tenemos 6 y sobre 3 eso es 2
p entonces coste 9 2p es igual a 1 ahora
vamos a tomar para valores intermedios
intentémoslo con qué te parece que te
parece 3 pi entonces cuando x es igual
es igual a 3 espn
tenemos coseno de un tercio por 3 spin
eso es coseno de pi y cocinó de pi es
igual a menos 1 entonces bueno aquí
vamos a seguir así que se va a mirar se
mirarán algo así la gráfica voy a hacer
el mejor intento estoy haciendo un mayor
esfuerzo para dibujarlo
para ir bueno ya viste que así se va a
ver la gráfica ahora
para ir de de la función coseno de x a
la función de igual a coste no de un
tercio de x esencialmente lo que estamos
haciendo es estira de estirar la función
por un factor de 3 puedes ver que el
periodo es tres veces más largo aquí el
período aquí fue de 2 pin y acá desde
aquí fue de 2 pin pero acá en esta otra
función acá es de 6 pi cierto entonces
aquí puedes ver en esta función el
periodo fue de 6 pin ahora nos falta
hacer una última transformación en lugar
de tener coste no de un tercio de x
debemos tener menos 2.5 coseno de un
tercio de x aquí ya tengo aquí tengo
entonces 2003 p4p
5 y 6 p y muy bien nuestra meta es
dibujar la gráfica para que igual bueno
aquí tenemos aquí lo hicimos en una
escala en una escala de 0 a 6 pi y acá
de 0 a 2 espn son funciones periódicas
seguirán indefinidamente en ambas
direcciones pero ahora queremos graficar
de igual a menos 2.5 coseno de un tercio
de x entonces dado este cambio ahora x
menos 2.5 que será bueno primero hay que
hay que pensar en ciertas cosas cuál fue
la amplitud en las primeras dos gráficas
amd amplitud en estas primeras dos
gráficas podemos pensar en esto como
bueno de dos maneras puedes pensar en
esto como la mitad de la distancia entre
el valor mínimo y el valor máximo en
ambas gráficas el valor mínimo es de
menos 1 y el valor máximo es de 1 la
diferencia es 2 entonces la mitad de 2
es 1 así que la amplitud aquí es igual a
1 o puedes pensarlo como bueno es el
valor absoluto del coeficiente que es
aquí implícitamente aquí tenemos un 1 y
el valor absoluto de 1 es 1 así que cuál
será la la amplitud para esta función la
amplitud será el valor absoluto de lo
que están multiplicando a la función
coseno la amplitud en este caso será
igual al valor absoluto de menos 2.5 lo
cual es igual a 2.5 y ahora con esto
multiplicado por el menos 2.5 que
provoca a en que en qué manera
transforma la gráfica pensemos un poco
si multiplicar aún por un coeficiente
positivo 2.5 se alargaría en cada punto
crecería por un factor de 2.5 cierto
pero estamos aquí multiplicando por un
menos 2.5 entonces en cada punto lo que
va a hacer es estirar pero luego voltear
la función o reflejar la sobre el eje de
las x eso es lo que está haciendo esta
está alargando pero reflejando sobre el
eje de las x
ahora cuando x era cero tuvimos uno en
este caso pero ahora voy a multiplicar
ese uno por uno
punto 5 y entonces aquí en menos 2.5
bueno de hecho quiero dejar esto bien
claro así que en este punto aquí sería
aquí sería menos 3 aquí es menos 3 y acá
estrés positivo
entonces este es menos 2.5 dibujo una
línea punteada para obtener referencia
entonces cuando nuestra función cuando
coseno de un tercio de x es cero no
importa por qué por qué número
multiplique 0 0 por lo que sea es 0 así
que aquí coseno de un tercio de x será
menos 1 en el caso de x igualdad 3 y qué
va a pasar con seno de un tercio vemos
que es menos uno menos uno por menos 2.5
eso es igual a 2.5 positivo entonces
aquí aquí tenemos voy a dibujar acá en
2.5 aquí está aquí está 2.5 entonces
aquí sería el valor que buscamos
luego cuando coseno de un tercio de x es
igual a cero otra vez obtenemos cero
muy bien entonces aquí es cero
y finalmente coseno de un tercio de x
cuando x es igual a 6 pi coseno de un
tercio de x es igual a 1 en 61 x menos
2.5 cuánto es en efecto es menos 2.5 así
que nos regresamos a este punto y ya
estamos listos para hacer la gráfica de
esta función de igual a menos 2.5 coseno
de un tercio de x y la gráfica se mira
se mira algo así después baja
hasta menos 2.5 así se ve la gráfica de
esta función muy bien entonces lo que ya
viste viste lo que pasó poniendo este un
tercio aquí alargo la gráfica incremento
el periodo por un factor de 3 luego
multiplicando los por menos 2.5
obtenemos esto volteándolo reflejándolo
en el eje de las x ahora bien entonces
bueno por lo tanto aquí lo que hace este
menos 2.5 es reflejarlo y aquí la
amplitud es de 2.5 baja lo que puedes
ver bueno lo puedes pensar como en la
diferencia entre el valor máximo y el
valor mínimo de 5 la mitad de eso es 2.5
acá si multiplicamos esta gráfica por
2.5 obtiene es algo que se mira así algo
así
bajaría y después llegaría aquí y luego
sube entonces se miraría algo así pero
como tenemos un número negativo lo que
hicimos fue voltear la gráfica
reflejarla sobre el eje de las equis y
bueno espero te hayan servido nos vemos
pronto